dumb you're gonna betray your brothers
and shatter your family I'm taking you
down so right up come and get it
[Music]
this is crazy
[Music]
why are you always yelling yes it's got
a busy bee Villa hi max hi team listen
up
this crew is about family but the game
has changed now
[Music]
Dominic Toretto just went rogue you're
gonna turn your back on family I know it
looks bad don't give up on him so easy
we've only got one chance to make this
family whole again don't do this done
you ready one thing I can guarantee no
one's ready for this she's the very
definition of a tech terrorism there's
thousands of cars in this city and now
they're all mine now I know what it
feels like to be every cop ever chasing
us
[Music]
wait-wait-wait
[Music]
Oh
Londyn Abu Dhabi Cuba our paths have
crossed before dawn you just didn't know
it I think I need to remind you why you
chose to be here I got no choice
if you gotta catch Dom you got me little
help if you want to tell me why you just
put me in a room with this team crumpets
Eton criminal you don't think that tight
t-shirts cutting off the circulation
he'll Brian you should get me this a
nice you guys are gonna work together
love to I've been waiting for this we
got a tank
now what's up baby
[Music]
you just don't give up either you
thought this was gonna be a street fight
take the wheel
what
which is crazy all right you get style
points for that one I don't know why
you're doing this but I know one thing
you love me
you
[Music]
you